施しは許しまへんで食堂のおばちゃん
分かった
ちゃんと食べるね
今日羽鳥社長です比較バルーンスライムの風船ねんぞというものがあります空忍法光る
悪口のずつバルーンスライムつってから夢なんですけどもストローを使うとコック作っ
て膨らむやつですねで光るともガキどもが大喜び
まあ光ってるなんで光るのすいませんちょっと開けてみましょう
何が止まる一回やってみることだってめんどくさい
俺様として時間かかるノアでもすぐ出来そうだぞえっとまずこれに入れています
クローンに流し込んで行く桜
をは普通にすごい癒さにもすごく年か魔法水を入れますしていきます
goo
おーわっ分が山へえろいえろいえろなんかとってもエロチークしますなるほど
バーッ
脳震盪でもすごいスライムっぽくなってきたよ
もう出していいんじゃないかもだしてみます
あすごいできましたスライムですね形見の際ムって言ったところかな
大で僕が今回目をつけているのはこの別に光るとかあんまりどうでもいいですよへ風性
を作りたいわけでございますをやっておいてへストローカー脅威
積み込んで息を機かけると膨らむというわけでございます
[音楽]
4位
某
すごい楽しいほんと時間とかなあー
近いという線ブルーがあります光 brain たくさん準備してみたんですけども
とりあえず1回超巨大な白井を作っておきましょう
これだけの量があるとザルバと別人たちんじゃないって言っても時間がかかってしまう
のでこれを作った過程をまとめてこの瓶で言ってやっちゃいますでは以下
はいこれなかなか驚異的な風船ができるのではないかと予測しているところであるん
ですけれどもベスじゃあもう全部出てきます
はい0入りました
[音楽]
次はこの8魔法水を全部入れていきますコップにこれ済みれた後にまとめてこうやって
入れて振って完成していきます
[音楽]
よし入って夕食で全部入りましたはいだけで今からですこれをこれに打つ込んでいくと
さっきと同じ半分になるはず
いきます
いやーたーーーうーん
エアーマってそんなことで早くシェイクしないという
wh
こうすると多分さっきと同じ電気だとドンこだま t ことですダーってよもう固まっ
た
おっ
th
敵たちもほっ最初に作ってるとフルーツをさせないと
相次いで完成しました調教ないなぁある財務ですこのサイズでバルーンになるそして
光るというとやっぱなったね視聴価値の高い世代のでございますちょっと入った平瀬て
みますか
あれスライム
おおおお
結構でかいんじゃない時で巨大するんできたわけなんですけども
多分すとろーず膨らませることができませんどこで送り込める空気量に対してこの g
本体がでかすぎるんで空気量が足らないんですよねたぶんということで今回この超巨大
バルーンスライム膨らませるために準備したものはこちら
プライヤーそうドライヤーならば強力な風をこぽんさんといっ
送り込め
多分コレット相対的に同じぐらいの掛け合いに勤めてる弾で数多いのでしっかりこいつ
和風生までたどり着くことがで言うと僕は考えました
ではやっていきましょうできたぁホントにはいつでもサイズ感的にはちょっと来なきゃ
いっぱい風船になっちゃう可能性もありますよねまだしか平べったくして泥を置いて
おりたためと両端を持って
3つを入れると膨らんでいきますいきますツリー
to burn
car
rar
見えた見えた見えた見えたぞジュークの問題ですそこの手段自体がもう質量が重すぎる
んで重力でこっち膨らますと思わせ結構
はぁんってなっちゃうんで次した負けだってみましょう玉置な
超でかくなりますよこっちの下きましたを聞いていきます
3一通バーンッ
3 d
car
昭和ん
me
beaune
うううう
car
me あった